l'aer est fêtée réussi ou pas oui non
oui oui florian toi à moi c'est
évidemment un grand oui j'étais sur mon
florian voilà donc serré pourquoi parce
que je pense qu'on peut pas tout la
journée a expliqué que les codes de la
communication politique ils sont
dépassés qui n'intéressent plus personne
que les politiques ne parlent pas comme
nous qui ne comprennent pas le monde
dans lequel on vit quand ils ne sont pas
sur youtube où les réseaux sociaux comme
tous les français
et quand il tente des paris audacieux
comme celui d' emmanuel macron ici venir
les critiques et a expliqué que ce n'est
pas le rôle du président que ça
désacralise la fonction présidentielle
on peut quand même s'interroger sur la
désacralisation de la fonction
présidentielle avant est ce que c'est
mieux de mettre un casque de se cacher
pour aller voir sa maîtresse est ce que
c'est mieux m rockman de jouer de
l'accordéon à l'elysée pour parler un
public qui n'est pas le sien moi je ne
le crois pas je crois qu emmanuel macron
il fait là le pari de parler à
l'intelligence de millions de jeunes qui
vont découvrir l'homme qu'il est un
homme comme un autre et ça c'est un pari
très intéressant à l'heure où il ya un
français sur quatre qui ne se déplace
pas au second tour de l'élection crédit
à la jsms ça ne l'intéresse pas salut
cyril 400000 gilet jaune dans la rue on
n'a jamais eu le privilège d'être reçu
par le président grand n'importe quoi et
zubi ce qu'il a fait ils oublient ce
qu'il a fait aux jeunes pendant un an
jean pierre alanche d'abord je pense que
si c'est bien joué sur le sur la forme
sur la technique de qom et c'est parce
que c'est en fait le truc des manuels
macron sait qu emmanuel macron lemay en
top gun avec des rafales ça marche on le
met avec thomas pesquet dans la navette
spatiale ça marche on le mec un igloo et
un truc d'esquimaux ça marche mais qu'on
le déplace c'est bon c'est pas le
problème le problème comme martin sport
mon permanente
il est très bon acteur et ça le fait
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
justement on se fiche de qui et macro
emmanuel de sa marque de slips ou line
et ce qu'il a fait quand il était
stagiaire c'est pas le sujet en fait
macro emmanuel il n'est deux personnes
macro emmanuel il a tout à fait le droit
de s'amuser de rire de ce marais d'avoir
de l'humour et on est content pour lui
que le mec soit sympa qui soit cool
qu'ils soient beaux gosses que l'elysée
ça pète ça claque il ya des dorures
mais c'est pas le sujet en fait le sujet
c'est que le gars il est juste président
de la république française est le
président de tous les français et il y a
une si vous voulez une sorte de
sacralité et le général de gaulle
lui-même regard d intervilles ce qu est
l équivalent
des jeux télé réalité donc ce n'est pas
le sujet mais le général de gaulle il a
été deux personnes et tous les
présidents de la république sont comme
ça ils sont allés regarder top chef
macron est arrivé au pouvoir
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit le premier truc
qu'il a dit il a dit écoutez moi
maintenant ça suffit on va arrêter cette
com et on va arrêter se déballonner
devant tout le monde
maintenant moi j'ai droit à ma vie
privée et je vais être juste présent à
appliquer ça a fonctionné dans un
premier temps aux lattes et jupiter
il est arrivé tout seul souvenez vous
avec les pyramides etc il a repris un
gamin un jeune j'ai regardé la vidéo
avant de dire je regarde la vidéo il a
repris le jeune je n'y ai emmanuel manu
payet non je suis monsieur le président
la république
et ça le faisait complètement mais là
maintenant on peut plus non mais là
c'est qui c'est qui ces mikron m'allume
annuel et enfin c'est youtube heures ça
ne va pas et en plus il l'a fait s
qualité de président de la république
dans la maison de tous les français
quels elysées c'est le mélange des
genres qui ne va pas que macro lui-même
le fasse c'est très bien qu'ils soient
sains pas très bien mais hollande était
sympa de gaulle était pas très sympa est
ce qu'on demande à un président de la
république d'être sympa et ses salons je
crois pas du tout alors ils ont aussi
fait un concours de métal dans le jardin
des idées ou par l'elysée on peut
regarder un concert de métal au garde à
vous monsieur le président dans les
jardins de l'elysée voici un concert
privé de groupes ultras vingt huit
messieurs
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors y allait y aller plus alliés qui
ne sont pas content heureux qu'elle ait
aussi alors qu'annie ça ne va pas plus
loin bah moi je fais partie des vieux
schnock qui disent qu un président c'est
un président et c'est pas là pour faire
du au dessus c'est pas là en plus j'ai
vu dans l'interview ça parle d'eux un
petit peu de moins de juin exactement ça
parle d'alcool au volant ça parlait
l'autre
enfin l'autre monsieur emmanuel macron
ça le fait marrer donc je trouve ça
vraiment limite moi tout ce que je
demande c'est pas de connaître emmanuel
macron je veux connaître un président
qui est là et qui porte à penser à mes
élèves
la mort de monsieur masson va apprécier
d'ailleurs je pense mériter au carton il
a pris deux balles pour arrêter des mecs
qui vendait de la ve et l'autre qui
rigole on dit les vieux d'abord oui mais
moi j'aurais dû bien aimé mais d'abord
honnêtement j'ai trouvé ça pas de routes
sur l'ensemble
moi je suis ravi qu'ils se fassent ça
crie déjà donné sur votre mot non plus
mais vous et moi j'essaye pas oui je
suis en meilleure santé
je suis ravi qu'il fasse sa crise
d'adolescence et qu'ils décompressent si
c'est un moyen d'être mieux ailleurs
pour le reste du temps tant miam et en
os mais mes parents oui et puis en plus
cependant mal absent alors si quelqu'un
fait 20 millions de vues en devant les
18 24 ans adore le baby beel il va
prendre cinq lots de manivelle juste
pour le faire alors dit la prime en plus
grand nombre de jeunes moi je trouve ça
bien certain de jean il ya plein de gens
qui lisent des politiques vont bien
shana pourquoi il fait pas la rochelle
aussi mais notre attention il faut des
débats oui c'est ça c'est ça la
politique
pourquoi le message politique merci quoi
je les remercie juste quelques infos sur
les coulisses du tournage de là
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
c'est emmanuel macron qui a décidé de
faire cette interview c'est à son
initiative pour ça oui comment une image
full tilt
le tournage a eu lieu la semaine
dernière ça a duré quatre heures montage
très rapide pour éviter des fuites et
l'elysée a donné quand même des
consignes à maclas et carlito ne pouvait
pas aborder tous les sujets faire
n'importe quoi donc il n'était pas
totalement libre après ils ont leur
quand même assez libre il est désolé il
est plutôt cool avec eux alors sur le
dit j'ai des chiffres là un million de
gemmes 22000 j'aime pas 9 millions de
vues voilà les jeunes ont eu ce qu'ils
regardent bon et mes seins
ce n est pas un bulletin de vote pour
moi c'est dur et pectacle c'est de la
poudre aux yeux les jeunes méritent
mieux les jeunes ils veulent du boulot
un logement manger à leur faim il ya de
quoi se faire leur idée m'est pas
sympathique spectacle en face de lui
parle pas se régale moi je trouve ça
disait gracieux à l'égard des jeunes non
plus s'ils prennent en otage la 90 en
juillet des ans le 14 juillet mais le 14
juillet ça appartient à tout le monde le
regarde réciproque pour moi c'est
honteux
moi je veux juste parler monsieur la
floride 6 me qui flottait en parlons
mais vous vous avez un sérieux sur ce
que vous dites parce que vous prenez un
peu les français pour des cons quand
même penser et vous pensez que les
rester courtois
mais je suis à un moment donné un moment
donné il est vrai il dit que les
français ont besoin de voir emmanuel
macron comme il est mais est ce que vous
pensez sérieusement il ya un français
sur terre qui pensent qu emmanuel macron
il est comme ça il est cool gentille y
rigole machin mais ces puces et le
président que vous ancien président de
la république syrie dont le président de
la république ou aujourd'hui vous pensez
pas qu'il a autre chose à gérer oui on
sort d'une crise et non vous pensez
qu'il a besoin de se mettre en scène de
cet essai est venu
répondez lui mais je ne vais pas lui
répondre parce que je n'ai pas à lui
répondre au fond sa réaction
elle est intéressante sa réaction parce
qu'elle marque le clivage générationnel
on veut pas parler aux boomers réac qui
ne comprend pas le monde dans lequel on
vit et qu'il en soit ce cadre on veut
aussi le néon séduction de là je ne vous
ai pas loupé je crois donc alors allez-y
vous avez envie d'avoir un minimum de
respect de la bonne chose c'est qu'on
est habitué à ce qu'elles soient elles
les difficultés ici essayer de séduire
la jeunesse et donc il y a évidemment un
clivage générationnel entre ceux qui ne
comprennent même pas les codes qui
réside sur youtube ça soit donc
évidemment choqués par ce qui s'y passe
parce que le vieux qui regardent les
vidéos youtube il comprend pas ce qui
s'y dit comprends pas comment ça
fonctionne habituellement parce qu'il
n'a pas regardé les vidéos avant les
gens d'autres lanceurs mais c'est
évidemment le clivage qui ressort ici
dans l'opinion mais on peut pas
regretter que des millions de jeunes
s'engagent positivement sur la vidéo du
président du république vous pensez
qu'ils vont s'engager positivement mes
moyens
je crois que les commentaires et les
like positifs sont une arme et des
enfants qui ont regardé la vidéo
spontanément sur pole-emploi org et je
pense que sur le temps sur le fond que
sur la forme c'est très méprisante pour
la jeunesse vous dire pourquoi
non pas que la jeunesse elle n'a pas le
droit de se marrer et c'est wii sega
d'ailleurs ils sont dans leur jean mois
spam c'est pas mon genre de beauté mais
honnêtement peut-être que ça parle j'en
sais rien ils font bien le tard après
bon si c'est pas du tout le sujet moi
j'ai envie de penser que pour parler
d'abord la politique je vous rappelle
que la politique c'est ce qui nous
rassemble tous et il faudrait peut être
arrêter de diviser les gens entre hommes
femmes noirs blancs jaunes à dieu ça
compte et ça c'est un truc de marketing
en fait et je pense que les gens du
marketing ils ont pris le pouvoir à
l'elysée
et qu'en réalité c'est une technique de
marketing s'appelle l'engagement vous
prenez une marque d'engagement voulait
parler aux jeunes pour les pepsi et vous
fait un lien entre pepsi et donc la
macro il se pense comme une marque il a
pris la marque
carlito et mater la cinquième est bon de
marquer mais deux c'est revenir de sitôt
le combat bizarre
voilà le grand vide
pourquoi moi je chéris que les ai jamais
invité mène dans l'émission ici c'est
juste en fait un jour il m'a appelé pour
qu'il fasse une vidéo pour eux est de
voir je les fais et après on les a
appelés pour faire un truc et ils ont
dit qu'il n'avait pas le temps voilà
donc c'est vrai que voilà donc voilà je
je je vois là j'aime pas trop gêner
cette attitude
après on n'a rien contre eux c'est très
bien c'est sur le fond c'est à dire que
parce qu'il ya la forme mais il ya le
fond qui est plus intéressant me
semble-t-il est là sur le fond ils ne
parlent pas l'avenir il ne parle pas de
la planète ils ne parlent pas c'est pas
les deux clips la première fois depuis
1945 les jeunes ont fait la queue pour
manger il est au courant de ça ils ont
été enfermés caméra pendant un an pour
sauver des ehpad ces sales histoires et
maintenant il va leur faire un des
petites cabriole de chimpanzés sur le
sol n'est pas légal
je faisais en amazone en jeu suivante à
vue on n'avait absolument pas de contenu
lors c'était pas l'idée l'idée première
à tomber matthew play produits à vendre
l'ipad produit vous souhaitez les gestes
barrière celle merci merci merci merci